goo
みなさんこんにちは
はい早速ですがこの写真生まれたばかりの赤ちゃんの写真です
みなさんどんな気持ちになりますか
私は見た時とても幸せな気持ちになりました
人はただそこに存在するだけで誰かを笑顔にすることができる
そんなことを私は子供たちに教えてもらいました
でも考えてみてくださいここにいる皆さん一人一人もきっと
0歳の時があったと思いますこの0歳でこのように生まれ落ちてそして広がる社会
どんな社会どんな世界が広がっていたら皆さん嬉しいですか
子どもたちの命の始まりはこれからの未来の始まり
私は保育所を通してそして今子どもたちと携わる中でたくさんの気づきとたくさんの
学びをもらいました
今日はそれをみなさんとしここで白したいなと思っています
幼児期の重要性についてこれは文部科学省のホームページから採ってきたものです
私は子どもたちと携わる中で本当にこの幼児期の重要性について感じました
そしてその重要性についてもっと多くの人と共有したいもっと多くの人に知ってほしい
と思っています
さて私は保育所しています保育士で今のところに立ってるんですけれども
ちょっと変わった道で保育士になりました
大学で福祉を学んだ後独学で保育士の試験の勉強して資格を取りましたその後
保育所にはならずに一般企業に勤めて営業していました
私と子供達との出会いは18歳の時です
ハンディキャップを持った子どもたちのところにボランティアに行ったことから始まり
ました
そしてこの写真にあるように perl の難民キャンプの幼稚園に行ってみたり
そして働きながらも小学生たちと一緒にキャンプをするそんなボランティアをしてい
ました
子どもたちと一緒に生活をしていく中でもっともっと子供たちについて知りたいとか
この子たちの世界を知りたいもっと人についていっぱい知りたいなと思うようになった
んです
そして会社を辞めて保育士になりました
保育者してみると毎日いっぱい射精した
こんな風に子供たちが立つようになるんだごはんを食べるようになるんだ
トイレに行けるようになるんだ毎日当たり前のことかもしれませんがすごく素敵な発見
をたくさんさせてくれました
保育士をやって少し落ち着くとふと子供達のまわりのことが目に入ったんです
そんな時ある気づきを私はれました
私たちの作り出す環境ひとつで子どもたちの人生が変わってしまう
そしてその先に子供たちが作っていく日本の未来が変わっていく
そんな風に保育士の仕事も重要性について気づいたんですでもこれって保育士だけだと
思いますか
そうではなくて私は親御さんたちやそして社会をつくっているすべての大人たちがこう
いうふうに意識をしたら何かが変わるんじゃないかなと思っています
さて突然ですが今日車で来た方いらっしゃいますか
はい
はい何の車乗ってますか
とちょっと突然に聞いてみましたが
実はこんなことは5歳児の初対面の子に言われたことがあったんです
まあ正解不正解はないと思いますが私はこの時言葉が出なくて
なぜかショックを受けましたそのときはわからなかったんですけれどもなんでショック
を受けたのか
お家に帰って考えてみました
すると
気づいたことがありました子どもたちは社会の鏡なんじゃないかそう思ったんです
きっと大人たちやこの社会の価値基準が子どもたちにとっても影響している
そんなこと思った時に保育士としてできることもちろんたくさんできることはあります
がこの社会の影響力の大きさに私はすごく
限界を感じました
そしてさらに
まぁこんなような言葉よく効くかもしれませんが
例えばうちのコーチ月が無いのよねなんて言うかよ子さんたちがいた時に
私は好奇心旺盛でいろんなことにチャレンジして素敵箱ですねと言ったんですが
なかなかこうストンと落ちない感じがしました
もしかしたら親御さんたちも何かの向社会のプレッシャーに
そんな風に思ってしまっているだけなのかなぁなんて思いました
またあるとき電車に乗っていた時に俺よりももうちょっと厳しめの言葉で子どもたちに
話をしているような方を見つけました
その時私はすごく心が苦しくて子どもたちの心の声や子どもたちが今思っていること
それはどこに行ってしまうんだろう
誰が聞いてくれるんだろうそう思った時に私は保育士としてもっと子どもたちに
寄り添って何か声を聞いてそれを発信できないだろうか
そんなことを思いました
親への子育てサポートができたらもしかしたら子どもたちの未来が変わるかもしれない
そして日本世界が変わっていくんじゃないだろうかそんな風に思ったんです
そして保育園を止めて外に飛び出すことにしました
といってもどこの保育園ですかとまぁ当たり前に聞かれます
でも私はそうではなくて保育園のその先の社会をフィールドにした保育士としてこども
未来プロデューサーという新しい仕事を作ろうと決めました子どもの未来を保育士の
専門性を持ってもっと広く社会を変えていけないだろうか
そんなことを思って外に飛び出たんですそして高天店といろんなコミュニティに歩いて
いるうちに1人
の保育士に出会いました彼女もまた保育士として子どもたちの未来のことを真剣に考え
てそして社会を変えていきたいそんな強も思いを持った一人の保育士でした
私たちはすぐに意気投合して何か子供たちのためにできないか
保育所集めたりいろんな大人たちと子どもたちの未来について話すような会をしました
そして今では保育士2人で起業して会社をやっています
私たちは保育士の専門性をフルに生かして社会をデザインしていく
さまざまな企業さんや様々な方と手を取り合いながら子どもたちにとって本当にいい
ものそして異人そんなものをデザインしていけないだろうか
そんな事を日々考えて仕事をしていますそして私たちが大事にしている子供は保育園
だけの子どもではなくこの車
海にいる子供たちそして日本を越えて世界地球にいる子どもたちすべて大事な命です
そんな子供たちのために私たちは保育士としてできることを発信しています
そんな社会デザインの一つの事例を少しご紹介させてください
今言ったように保育士の専門性を少しだけおすそ分けをできる場所を作れないかなと
思いました
それは保育園を超えていろんな方に私たちが見てきた沢山の子供達の良さやいろんな
ケースそしてたくさんのご家族を見てきましたのでそれを市ができないかそんな風に
思ったんです
そこで大事にしたことがいくつかあります
まず子どもたちは特に乳幼児期が子どもたちは一人で外に歩いて行くことができないの
で親御さんたちがいきたいと思うような環境を設定しなければならないなぁと思いまし
た
そして選んだ場所が初めはカフェでやりました
大人も子どももお互いに幸せな気分だったり少しリラックスできたりそんな環境を作る
ためにカフェという場所を選びました
そしてここで大事にしたことがありますそれは大人も子供も両方ともが学びがあったり
楽しみがあったり何かリラックスできたり素敵の気持ちになるような環境の設定をする
ということです
例えば大人の人には私たちが育児相談をしたりとか
何か美味しいものを食べてもらったりちょっとだけ子どもと離れて少し自分だけの時間
を作ってもらったりそんなことをするだけで親御さんたちはすっと心が楽になります
子供たちの隣に笑顔でいられるような環境というところをサポートするお手伝いを
しようと思いました
そして子供たちの方はというと
こんな感じです
まあ日常にあるもので設計をしているんですがそこにも理由があります
子どもたちは何もなくても遊びますみなさん思い出してみるといろんな場所で子供い
ますがそこにあるもので遊べます
まあそれに近い環境を作るためにをリサイクル素材だったりとか
手に入りやすいものであえて構成をしています
ここで子ども達が自分が表現したいことを自分が好きな素材を知って自分らしく表現し
て何かつくり出していく
もしくは何かで遊んでいくそんな環境を作ることを大事にしていますそしてお母さん
たちにもお父さんたちにも遊びのヒントを持って帰ってもらえるようにおうちでも用意
できるような簡単な素材にしました
今お話しした設定が揃うとですねこんな風に遊びが展開していきます
子どもたちこれ8耐名の子どもたちです自分たちで遊びを作り出してつながりあって
楽しむそんなことを周りにいる親御さんたちは見て何かを感じて帰っていくそんな場所
づくりをしました
子どもたちが楽しんでいるとまあこれが sns の効果もあったんでしょう
3回目にして60家族きてしまってカフェに入らなくなりました
そこで私は考えましたどうしたらこれを続けていけるんだろうと
そんな時またひらめいたんです
子どもたちが住む世界は車庫の社会すべてだから使っちゃいけない場所なんかないし
きっと言っちゃいけない場所もないし色んな場所でこれをやったらどうだろうかそんな
アイディアを一つを走りながらですね企画しながらそこにいる子どもたちそこにいる親
御さんたちの声そして保育士たちの
いろんな声を聞いて形にしていくことにしたんです
例えば公園ではこんな形でなかなかおうちでこんなことできないと思いますそれを
思いっきりやらせてあげられるように保育士たちの仲間に協力してもらったりとか
ゴミ袋を着てもらって自由にできるようにそんな風な環境を作っていますでも先ほどの
素材やルールや環境の設定など基本的なものは一緒にしました
ほかにもこんなふうに商店街で販売体験をしたりあとはライブハウスで思い切り楽器で
遊べるような環境をつくりました
ここでですねまぁ親御さんたちが周りにいるんですけれどもやっぱり子どもたちは親御
さんたちの自分の好きなことや連れてって言ってくれる場所
その中で自分の世界を選択するというような
まだまだちっちゃい子たちなので自分たちでこう外に出て選択肢を広げていくことは
できないかもしれません
ということで家族丸ごと
自分たちではできない体験だったりとかなかなか外に人家族でいけないような企画って
いうのを保育士たちと一緒にやっていくことにしたんです
すべてのイベントでですね衣装のルールがあります
それを今からご紹介しますが
たった4つだけしかありませんそれが行われるとですねこんな風に子どもたちが自然に
笑顔になります
そうしていくと親御さんたちは何回も来ますうちもここに来るとすごく笑顔が素敵で
もっとこういう機会を作ってあげたいとか
おうちでこれをするにはどうしたらいいんだろうとか親御さんたちも今度自発的に自分
達で考え始めるんですそんなルールをご紹介しますひとつめほとのだから子供だからと
決めつけない子
と大人もできないこともできることもあります同じように子どももできることもでき
ないこともあります
人間として同じです
なので完璧な人もいません
だからこそここはフラットで誰もが自分らしく入れるということを設定しています
そして2つめ頭ごなしに否定をしないこと
今井いろんなところで禁止事項が増えていますが私たちがやる時には否定語を使わない
よしってもらっています
もちろん危険のときにを食べますが
走ってほしくないところを走ってた時に歩いてねーということもできるんです
私たちが発する言葉に注意を傾けてもらってどんな言葉を子供たちにかけるかそこに
意識をちょっとだけ置いてもらうようなことを2つ目においていますそして3つ目
まず共感すること
たぶん皆さんも経験あると思うんですが子供達って大人がちょっと理解できないような
ものを作って自信満々で見せできたりしませんか
そんなときになにそれというのかそれともまあ何か丸めて作ったんだねと共感して
あげることで子どもたちはその先にいろんな説明をしてくれたりいろんな世界を発信し
てくれるんじゃないでしょうか
阿蘇してさ
英語4つめ価値観押し付けないことたとえば
チューリップを黒で書こうとしますみなさん止めますか
もしかしたらその子チューリップの影を先に書いたかもしれません
そういうふうにしてちょっと大人が見守っていくとまた子どもたちの世界が広がる可能
性が増えていきます
たった4つだけです
子供の隣で私たち大人がどんな風にいるかそしてどんな環境を選んでどんなものを置い
てどんな言葉をかけるか
それで子どもたちは持っている力をどんどん外に出していくことができます
それが子どもたちにとって一番重要なんじゃないでしょうか
さてこの間実施したイベントを一つご紹介させてください
これは skype でフィリピンのストリートチルドレンの子どもたちと交流した
イベントです
日本側の3歳ぐらいの男の子でした紙皿に洗濯バサミをつけてこう
ライオンを作りましたこれ見てライオンだよと向こうの子に見せたんです
そしたら本物見たことあるというふうに向こうのかって言いました
日本の子たちはあるよ動物園に行けばいるじゃんというふうに言いました
すると向こうの子たちは僕たちお金がないから
ライオン見たことないんだよとにこやかに明るく教えてくれました
私はその時思ったんです
子どもたちは環境を設定していくだけで遊びの先に公のように学びを得ていく
それこそが学びの本質なんじゃないかなと思いました
もし私たちが貧困のことやフィリピンのことそれと事例のことを伝えようと思っても
きっとライオン話は出てこないと思います
この時にはもしかしたら子どもたちは理解してないかもしれませんがきっといつの日か
その同じ言葉を聞いたりとか何かのタンニングでこの日のことを一人でも思い出して
くれたらいいなと思います
私たちを飛ばの役割とはそういうふうにいろんな選択肢を子供たちに与えることじゃ
ないかなぁと思うんです
そしてこの写真皆さん何を感じますか
子どもたちの視線
どこにありますか
これ遊びと言いますか
私たちはこれも遊びだと思っています
子どもたちはカラーセロファン一つでいろんな光の世界や
このようにコミュニケーションを取りながら人のことを知ったりいろんなことを観察し
ています
遊びの可能性というのをすごく感じているんですけれどもやっぱり何かを作り出すこと
だけが遊びではなくて子供達からしたら何かをつかむこと何かを触ること何かを壊す
ことすべて遊び部なのかもしれません
そういうふうに大人たちが考えたらもっと子どもたちの遊び場遊び方が増えていくん
じゃないかなと
持っています
遊びは人と人とをつなぎ人と世界をつなぐ
子供たちはこの世界に生まれ落ち自分たちで遊びながらいろんな世界の扉を開いていく
んじゃないかなと思っています
さてそろそろ最後になりますがもう一つ私が1歳児クラスの担任をしていた時のことを
話しします
1歳児クラスの15人の子どもたちはまだハイハイの子もいました
そしてまだなかなかうまくおしゃべりができない子たちの集まりでした
でもそこで起こったことに私はすごく心が動きました
子ども達は毎日思いっきり笑ってをもいけないて思い切り人とケンカして言葉がなく
たって人と人とがつながっていきます
そんな子供たちの光景を見た時多様性社会ってもしかしたらこういうことを言うんじゃ
ないかなと
法律の部分を私は何か感じることができました
子どもたちはそういう力をもともと持っています
その力を大人たちがどんな環境を作るかでそのまま大きく育て行くかそれともそうで
なくなってしまうか決まってしまうのかもしれません
もしその力をそのまま伸ばすことができたらきっと今この地球にあるいろんな問題
差別や貧困や戦争やこんな問題がなくなるんじゃないか
そういうことを彼らは教えてくれました
その力を守っていくためにもしかしたら先ほど言った4つのルール
これは子どもたちだけではなくて
友達夫婦関係そして家族もしかしたら企業の中でもそうかもしれませんが大人だから
子供だからと決めつけないことを頭ごなしに否定をしないこと
まず共感すること価値観押し付けないことぜひ皆さん
一つでも出来れば今日からやってみてください
さて最後になりますが今日もどこかで新しい命がたくさん生まれています皆さんは
どんな社会を子どもたちにプレゼントしたいなと思いますか
そしてその社会はきっと私たちも幸せにもつながってくるんじゃないかなと思います
今日は私のこのアイディアをシェアすることで誰かが誰かのために何かできたり少しで
も気づきを持って一歩前に進んでもらえたらきっと未来はもっと良くなるんじゃないか
なと思っていますご静聴ありがとうございました